التغير حدث كما ذكرنا لكن لنظام فقط ولا
الانتفاضه خمدات غير ان شيئا ما تغير وائل
الابد الشتاء القادم ينبا بعواصف لن تمر
بهدوء المجتمع التحماء واتحد بشكل غير
مسبوق وهناك عفويه وصدق للاحتجاجات وربما
هي السبب والدليل فيما يجري في اقصى
الشمال يسمع صده في اقصى الجنوب حتى
الفئات الاكثر تشددا والقريب من النظام
وليس الاصلاحيون فقط ان حازت للانتفاضه
فلم تبقى عائله متدينه الا هو قتل لها ابن
او ابن في الاسابيع والسنوات الاخيره وهذا
ما يقوله المؤرخ ستيفان ضد يونس مؤلف كتاب
حراس الثوره الاسلاميه وكتاب علم الاجتماع
السياسي الدوله قراءته اعتمدت على مداهمات
قوات الامن لاكثر الاحياء تدينا كحي نرماك
الذي يقع العاصمه طهران ولا يبدو ان جرح
الشعب سيلتئم قريبا بل سيستمروا ولاجيال
وسيبقى هم اسقاط النظام مرتبط بكل الالام
هما مشتركا للشعب الايراني بقوميته
المختلفه
اخطاؤه النظام كثرت والمعالجه تاخرت رئيس
مستعد للاستماع للمطالب كما قال لكن الثقه
فيه عدم التقريبا الشعب بجميع اطيافه
وفاته يتمرد وابطال الرياضه من المتصدرين
المشهد واليكم عدوتني في فريق السنوكه
شريف ايران خليفه